foreign
the top business stories live from the
Sky News City Studio
NHS England expands virtual Wards
offering hospital care level care to
thousands of people at home I speak with
one of the companies providing the
service
which is just another bank of England's
inflation forecasting experts say it
should have spotted red flags
and used to combat sanctions busting at
sea
[Music]
good afternoon this is business life
with Ian King the NHS has announced an
expansion of its so-called virtual Wards
saying it will provide Hospital level
care for tens of thousands of children
at home the announcement coincides with
the health services 75th anniversary
today NHS England says the hospital at
home service is already the largest of
its kind in the world and will now
expanded to cover every region of
England well dockler is the leading
provider of virtual awards for the NHS
its Chief commercial officer is Tom
Breeze and he joins me now Tom welcome
to you for the uninitiated what is a
virtual Ward
oh yeah thank you very much for having
me
um so butcher Awards basically exists to
make sure that patients are only in
hospital when it's clinically necessary
for them to be there uh and what happens
is you provide patients with a box of
devices and often clinical capacity and
to monitor patients Vital Signs and
ensure that patient says safe in their
homes and can therefore be discharged
early from hospital if they were already
in hospital and all can remain in the
community and have their condition
managed there but can that always
replicate the quality of service that
one gets in a hospital Ward
so what's important to remember is that
the sorts of patients that are being
admitted onto these services and not the
sorts of patients that would otherwise
be in ICU they're patients who otherwise
would just have their symptoms monitored
and be checked on by a nurse or a doctor
maybe a couple of times a day on a on a
ward
um so for those patients actually what
we're able to do by continuously
monitoring their symptoms and making
sure that those are intelligently
checked and you could argue that they're
receiving a a more attentive service
than they would otherwise be in a
hospital and of course we can't forget
the patients who are now able to be in
hospital that otherwise would have been
waiting for the service because of this
additional capacity
how do you get paid is it on a fixed
term contract or is it on a per patient
basis
it's uh depends on how our providers
want to pay us so we're very happy to to
basically do whatever it is that the
local commissioner thinks is appropriate
generally that happens to be uh per uh
uh per patient rather a fixed their
basis and roughly how much do you think
you can save the NHS per patient
well so a uh a study done by the NHS
thought that where dockler was in use
with one NHS provider who was saving
about three pounds for every pound spent
on the service and we actually think
that number's probably gone up but it's
closer to five or six pounds but three
pounds is the the independent NHS
delivered figure
how have you managed to persuade the
clinicians to adopt it because they
can't be quite a conservative Bunch they
don't take kindly to their working
patterns being disrupted do they
so the clinicians are are fabulous and
so what we typically see is that there
are just extraordinary demands on
clinician time and you're right that as
a consequence sometimes it's hard to be
able to free up time in their day to
adopt a new service and but when you
explain that the benefits to patients
and our patient satisfaction rates are
about 99 genuinely at the moment and you
can play back some of the stories of
what it means to be a patient on this
sort of a service at home with a wife
with a dog eating their own food then
generally we find it's it's pretty easy
to um to get the clinicians on board of
course that it assumes that you have the
the time to speak with them in the first
place now the rollout uh is going to be
specifically aimed at uh children who
are receiving treatment you've done a
few trials I think in Dorset and in
Blackpool and in Dudley what did you
learn from those
yeah so working with children is
um is is a really interesting uh uh
issue I suppose because uh then what you
you assume is that these virtual Awards
have got to provide something that is is
capable of being understood by a
five-year-old
um but actually what you see is that in
in reality that five-year-old is always
having their care mediated by um their
parent normally but by somebody else you
might be involved in that camp too uh so
um so so we find that so long as you've
got a really
um well onboarded trusting relationship
with the person caring for the child
then actually it works and relatively
seamlessly and smoothly like any other
virtual deployment so we think it's a we
think it's a great idea all right Tom
got to leave it there I'm afraid good to
talk to you this afternoon thank you
fabulous thank you very much Ian
just a bit of a breaking news to bring
you there's been a second protest by
just stop oil protesters on court 18 at
Wimbledon I think we can show you uh
what's happened obviously there was a
disruption this afternoon earlier on at
10 past two here is the latest
match earlier in the day well that was a
very similar process
that didn't look like the right clip did
it somehow well uh anytime now I'm told
we will be showing you let's have a look
[Music]
[Applause]
for the second
well at least he didn't uh spoil the
grass like they did at uh Lords last
week
MP is on the treasury committee have
been told that the bank of England
should have spotted red flags that
inflation would have been higher than
forecast Stephen King from HSBC told the
committee the signs were there in early
2021.
saw others saw the first signs of
inflation surprising on the upside
against the background of seriously weak
economic activities that normally when
you've got seriously weak economic
activity you expect inflation surprise
on the downside to the Practical
surprising on the upside not just on the
UK but in the US and the Eurozone
suggests that something was changing
relative to the history of the previous
30 years the second thing the second
thing I would note
is that if you move away from the model
and think about some of the monetary
indicators that were coming through at
the time
um particularly in the US less so in the
Eurozone in the UK there was incredibly
powerful money supply growth in 2020.
now you might say
you know the relationship between money
and the economy is not as strong as it
once was and I absolutely agree with
that but when you've got that kind of
strength coming through which is really
off the scale of what we'd seen
previously that strikes from being a red
flag it's an indicator that perhaps the
model as it was wasn't working as
reliably as the bank itself had
suggested
yeah Russia's war on Ukraine has
highlighted the importance of tackling
sanctions busting and nowhere is that
more pronounced than in the maritime
industry data suggests more than two in
five of all high-risk tankers are
affiliated to Russia and there has been
a rise in deceptive shipping practices
by such vessels well today saw the
London Stock Exchange groups strike a
deal with Windward in which is El seg
workspace platform we'll make use of the
latter's maritime AA powered technology
well joining me now is Wim was chief
executive Ami Daniel Ami welcome to you
what are the kind of behaviors on which
you hope to be able to pick up
first of all it's great to be here again
uh good afternoon uh it's very simple
last week you had the EU pass a very new
and aggressive regulation Banning
vessels from entering EU ports and
channels if they do basically one of
three main things one is turning off
Transmissions deliberately what's called
activity the second is doing
unauthorized or unreported ship to ship
transfer within 200 nautical miles of
the coast and lastly spoofing their
location which is something we have a
patent pending on and we broke in the on
the front cover of the New York Times so
these three things will be banning uh
vessel entrance into the EU and that's
exactly the core of the collaboration
with elsig where the 15 000 users or so
workspace will be now able to know that
real time and stay on the right side of
the law
and which sort of users are going to
find this most valuable presumably it's
Risk Managers and insurers I guess
well I think outside's uh customer base
is commodity Traders uh Charters
Equity traders who I think that's
predominantly their crowd we obviously
also work with uh insurance companies
seven of the 12 what's called p i clubs
uh third party insurance and many many
others uh about 170 of them uh currently
so I think it's becoming more and more
important and more and more aggressive
and this EU regulation is not just
talking about bulk uh trade which is oil
and Grain and so forth but also for the
first time ever containerized trade so
really the put in Invasion into Ukraine
has changed completely all the scene
around trade compliance what industry is
or is not allowed to do and who is
industry uh we signed last week of the
first contract with a pilotage company
uh so new sectors are brought into this
trade compliance game because the EU has
to find some way to enforce this oil cap
because right now it's not working that
well
now this is AI powered what does AI
contribute to the process
well you have millions of activities uh
every day in the world you have a
million and four million million support
calls uh turning off Transmissions a
million problems with these
transmissions and AI is there to really
sift through the noise and really
pinpoint the real uh Bad actors if you
will the flip side of compliance is
stopping training and I don't think in
this economy anybody wants to stop
trading right and Traders definitely
don't want to stop trading so AI is
there really to reduce What's called the
false positives and make sure you
actually make more business by using our
software not less business by using our
software and that's really one of our
USBS versus reading Legacy companies and
data providers with AI you do more
business not less business
okay I mean gotta leave it there I'm
afraid good to see you again this
afternoon thank you
see you soon
some other stories now and the
government issued debt today paying a
higher rate of interest than at any
point in the last 16 years the debt
management office which is the treasury
agency that manages the UK's borrowings
issued a guilt that's a UK Government
Bond which will pay investors an annual
return of 5.668 the guilt matures in
October 2025. well a guilt maturing on
that date was sold last month with a
yield of just 4.874 highlighting the
extent to which the government's
borrowing costs have risen in sharply in
a relatively short period of time while
investors offered to buy nearly three
times as many guilts as were being
auctioned and the sale raised 4 billion
pounds for the government
the financial conduct Authority has
confirmed for the first time that it's
investigating whether hedge fund manager
Chris binodi is a fit and proper person
to work in financial services in a
letter to the treasury committee nikhil
rathi the sca chief executive confirmed
the regulator had launched an ongoing
investigation into Mr Odie and his firm
OD Asset Management two years ago well
Mr Odie was ousted from The Firm last
month after the financial times reported
on a number of allegations of sexual
misconduct which he denies
the vehicle rental group read Northgate
has said demand is still outstripping
supplies it reported record results the
company whose importance in the white
van rental market means it's seen as a
barometer of small business activity
reported a pre-tax profit of 178.7
million pounds for the year to the end
of April that was up 35 on the previous
12 months or red Northgate which employs
more than 7 000 people and which
operates a fleet of more than 130 000
owned and leased vehicles said it
continued to enjoy robust demand
now the first half of this year was
largely a good one for stock market
investors in the face of continuing
concerns over the war in Ukraine the
impact of inflation and Rising interest
rates in most developed markets and the
ongoing trade dispute between the US and
China rumbling in the background but
with all of those factors still in place
what is the second half of the Year hold
well joining me now is Ken Fisher he's
founder and chairman of Fisher
Investments Ken good to see you again uh
when we spoke last time you were talking
about what you call the midterm miracle
and you thought that would drive markets
higher for this first half of this year
I mean for those who weren't uh watching
at the time explain what you meant by
that
so if you go through stock market
history and the U.S has the longest
accurate stock market history data uh
since the S P 500 data begins in 1925
the period that begins October 1st of a
U.S midterm election year
is the most consistently profitable
period over the next nine months of all
of stock market history no exception the
midterms bring in gridlock and gridlock
eliminates political risk aversion fears
because nothing big controversial gets
legislated which can take from these to
give to those the history of that nine
months is 92 percent positivity that
that is positive 92 percent of all those
uh periods and with an average return to
20 percent the midterm Miracle this time
in the S P 500 worked almost perfectly
with each of the three quarters positive
and the total positive 25 percent the
reality of all of that is that it
usually ripples somewhat around the
world because developed markets tend to
correlate that's a little different for
Britain but only a little different than
uh some other countries because of the
sectoral differences between between the
US and the UK which are important to
understand because each sector behaves
in its own way and we come back talk
about that but that's
the background for that the aftermath of
that's also very positive and we can
talk about that just a little less
positive well so so Ken do you think
this effect still has some way to play
through then
yeah so when you go back through that
long history
the back half is positive uh in the
United States a little over 75 percent
of the time uh which is much more than
the average return for the stock market
and with a average return for the back
half in total it looks like one of the
first two quarters now again in Britain
that may be a little confusing because
2023 hasn't been such a great year in
the market but for the global market and
for particularly big and particularly
Tech and particularly luxury consumer
goods you've had a gangbuster here
now you you obviously have a Keen Eye on
History because I know that you say that
this year so far has been like 1967 in
the markets for people who weren't
around there what was so particular
about that year
so the 6667 period is the closest period
in parallels to the 22-23 period in that
you had a midterm election you had a
bear Market in 1966 it began almost
exactly when the 2022 bear Market began
in the calendar year and ended almost to
the day when the bear Market in 2022
ended you know beginning of end of
September beginning of October you had
out of nowhere spike in inflation and
Central Bank hikes and uh uh foreign war
in that case that was thought to be
associated with all that the escalation
of the Vietnamese War you had a U.S
president who had been very popularly
elected two years earlier and then had
become increasingly unpopular so
unpopular that Lyndon Johnson could not
get renominated in the fourth year
service term 1968 uh and uh but you had
a 25 stock market year uh in 1967 uh in
a bull market that began and went on
after 1967. uh almost exactly to the day
of when this bull market began with a
midterm Miracle the uh the the other
thing to think about about that is that
the fourth year of president's terms not
only in the United States but also in
fact in Britain is markedly above
average uh with above average positivity
and above average returns uh and that
whole feature tends to run on through
the third and fourth year president in
terms of one final point we haven't had
a negative uh S P 500 since 1939 as
World War II was starting and it was
only down nine tenths of one percent
again there's so much more wanted to ask
you but we're out of time I'm afraid
good to see and hopefully see you again
soon thank you thank you thank you for
having me in
still to come here on business live will
take you through today's moves on the
markets don't go away
foreign
[Music]
we're about a month into the offensive
now
um and it's going okay
um you know there's quite a lot of
messages coming out from president
zielinski and others just kind of I
think canceling caution you know it
takes time it's going it's going okay
but it's not going fast and all no I
think nor should we expect it to be you
know the the ukrainians are trying to
attack through very very difficult
Russian defenses and it's it's slow and
costly progress well I think what what
you're seeing is across the front the
very long Frontage the Ukrainian forces
are they're pressing they're probing
they are making gains Hannah Malia who's
the Ukrainian defense minister Deputy
defense minister said yesterday they
took about nine square kilometers the
day before I mean that's a small amount
of terrain but it is forward movement
but I think what's actually going on is
is the thing you don't see and that is
kind of preparation in depth so lots of
and we saw this last year as well where
the ukrainians will be trying to prepare
uh in depth so they'll be trying to
destroy Russian Logistics their
Commander control which will make it
easier when they do break through well
the cost of human life you know we've
heard it from a number of people
recently just to again to manage our
expectations General milley the American
chairman of the Joint Chiefs said only a
couple of days ago you know this this is
this is costly Warfare and none of us
should ever lose sight of that you know
when we're when we're kind of looking on
our Twitter feeds or whatever you know
the reality is for the soldiers on the
front line This is brutally difficult
I'm increasingly reminded of my own
experiences in in mosul when uh we we or
the Iraqis liberate a mosul uh and and
the Offensive start with great fans
there in the world's get gays but the
reality is it takes a long time it took
nine months for the Iraqis to liberate
one city and they did that with the
worlds or the West uh air power and
support and of course the ukrainians
don't have as much air power as they
need
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Fly Emirates fly better
[Music]
European Equity markets have finished
the session in negative equity with weak
Chinese Services data Weighing on
sentiment all of the main indices in
Europe in negative territory leading
fallers include Casino the delayed and
French grocery chain off by 32 percent
on newsletter rescue refinancing is
going to all but wipe out existing
shareholders we're here in London the
ftse 100 finished off more than one
percent low and a broad-based sell-off
led by Chinese exposed stocks most
notably Prudential among other leading
Blue Chip fallers right now the proof of
nearly four percent there as you can see
other leading fallers in the ftse this
afternoon included legal in general
that's on news and accounting rule
changes will clip profits this year by
more than expected there are not too
many gainers to mention as legals off
two percent among the gainers there
weren't many of them but the educational
publisher Pearson up by nearly two and a
half percent that's on positive broker
comment outside the ftse the engineering
contractor Keller group is ahead by 12
on a train trading update but the
building materials group Sig that's off
eleven and a half percent after it won
this year's profits will be at the lower
end of market expectations on Wall
Street meanwhile equities have opened to
the downside after the 4th of July
public holiday the main focus is on the
minutes for the latest meeting of the
Federal reserve's Open markets committed
the market looking there for Clues on
the direction of U.S interest rates on
the foreign exchange markets meanwhile
well it's pretty quiet to be honest
Sterling more or less unchanged right
now against both the dollar and the Euro
the oil price has been interesting today
that's Claude bat most of its losses
from earlier in the session and it's now
positive territory ballot Brent crude
will currently set you back 76.58 a
barrel that's up a little under half of
one percent on the session joining me
now is Victoria scholar head of
Investment app interactive investment
Victoria welcome to you I'm in All Eyes
obviously on the fomc minutes this
evening
yeah that's actually absolutely right
we've got the minutes from the June
meeting due in just over an hour and I
think that the message is really going
to be that more work needs to be done
perhaps another half a percentage point
of more tightening this year could be
needed Stateside even after the Central
Bank kept rates on hold at its last
meeting and the suggestion really is
that June was very much a skip rather
than a pause or any kind of end to the
rate hiking cycle given that inflation
Still Remains considerably above Target
although it has come down uh quite a lot
and is a lot lower than we are here in
the UK we could also see some discussion
about the Outlook of the economy and the
potential of some weakness to come
through in the data and we know that the
FED likes to talk about the fact that it
is led by the data so that will be
important too
do you think the dollar is I mean the
Dollar's not really moved this afternoon
do you think all of this is priced in
yeah I think a lot of this is priced in
you know the FED has been pretty uh
clear in terms of its signaling when it
uh paused in terms of rates uh we did
see some downside to the dollar uh but
it does feel as though there is
potential for more upside uh if indeed
we do see those rate Heights come
through or if we see any of the
inflation data or the pce price index a
closely watched measure of inflation uh
come in hotter than expected and also if
we get any signs that the labor market
is also tighter than expected because
again there could be those second round
potential impacts on inflation and that
could lead to more monetary tightening
briefly if you will please Victoria a
bit of a risk off day today but Pearson
was one of the leading gainers today
yep that's right we saw that it was
all day rallying by over two percent
after UBS raised the stock to buy from
neutral and increased its price Target
on the stock it says that some of its
divisions are or the potential or gains
within some of its divisions such as
assessments and qualifications could
actually do a bit better than expected
so it argues that some of that isn't
being priced in yet but last year it was
really a stock market winner but some of
those gains have tailed off this year
very good Victoria could leave it there
thanks for joining me
that's it from me I'm back tomorrow
morning at 11 30. hope very much to see
you then thanks for joining me today
[Music]
[Applause]